your phone is costing you your fortune
society is conspiring all the time in
our culture
to completely distract you so you never
win all of us
have a mind it's the most powerful tool
in the world
built a smartphone it's put
machines that drive itself on mars yet
there's no manual for the mine
right want to be happy build a life not
just
a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something greater inside you too
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life
and learn the five simple ways to defeat
distractions
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one get rid of your phone with robin
sharma
your phone is costing you your fortune
it is an addiction it's a dopamine
addiction
break start the process of breaking your
addiction
to distraction here in this room today
you've invested in this you're a
learning investor the best
investment you can make is being in this
room
why would you spend it checking your
notifications looking at your email
looking at sms looking at
pictures of people's breakfasts or like
why would you do that
this is your life this is your career
this is your craft
this is your service to humanity
why would you why would you be checking
[Music]
your phone and if you look at a victim
if you look look at most people on the
planet
they're literally hooked to a white
screen they are wasting
their human potential hooked into some
social platform
that is creating empires for other
people
many people if not most people are now a
form of artificial intelligence
they're not living their brains
potential they're not living their
physiological potential
they're not living their creative
potential they're not living their human
potential
they're not living their economic
potential why because they're hooked to
a screen
it is the most frightening time in the
history of the world and it's the most
gorgeous time in the history of humanity
why
because it's never been so easy to be a
hero
because most people aren't doing it most
people are lost most people are hooked
so turn off your phones get
serious about this this is your game
this is your life
this is your sport and before you know
it you will be at the end we all know
that life goes by
in a blink rule number two create an
environment of total focus with dan lok
so how can you be productive in any
given time
during the day if you're interrupted all
the time i think
even entrepreneurs ceos they have this
like open door policy where
hey you know what my door is open come
talk to me anytime
i think it was one of the dumbest ideas
because it means you get
interrupted many many many times every
single day
and every time you get interrupted it
takes you certain mental bandwidth to
stay
and get back on track so when i am
working i unplug the phone
i create an environment that people
cannot reach to me
if i want to check messages i want to
check email or to get back to my team
that's fine
but if i am what i call the bad cave
moment
i unplug all communication my cell phone
my
none zero that's all my thinking time my
planning time my strategy time that's it
so when they cannot find you they cannot
interrupt you
when they cannot find you they cannot
distract you so
communicate with your team and people
around you and say hey i'm working on my
business
i'm building something here i'm working
on some very very important tasks
i need to get those done please give me
the space
during that time don't bother me same
thing in the office when i'm working
sometimes from home
when i close the door then jenny knows
right that she doesn't come in and
interrupt me right my wife knows that
nope that's dan's working time he needs
to stay focused
so put yourself in an environment that
you cannot be distracted
rule number three focus on your
obsession with ed meidlet
society is conspiring all the time in
our culture
to completely distract you so you never
win to just divert your focus and
attention look over here look at this
shiny thing look at this tv show look at
this sports team
worry about what's going on here in this
war and they get these different things
on television and our phones
and in our lives and just get us
distracted so we never get obsessed we
never get laser focused
for an extended period of time i think
there's a different level for you
i mean i think there's a different level
for you to get obsessed crazy laser
focused i say all the time
our obsessions become our possessions
but we won't possess them if we're not
truly obsessed i bet there's been a
person in your life you've been obsessed
with
if you're over 20 years old listen to
this more than likely you've had
somebody you're pretty obsessed with
haven't you that you wanted in your life
you wanted to date you want it as a
girlfriend or a boyfriend or a
significant other
how many times a day do you think about
them how many times a day did they
distract you from what you were doing
with just the thought of them
in other words this is what i want you
to understand when you're laser obsessed
focused
your obsession distracts you from what
you're currently doing not the other way
around
you're not really obsessed with it if
you're easily distracted
from it this is so important you right
now can test whether it's your obsession
with whether it distracts you constantly
the first thing you think of when you
wake up
last thing before you go to bed when you
have a big laugh it comes up when you
cry it comes up when you're watching tv
it comes up
when you're doing your regular job but
it's your side hustle that comes up you
can't stop thinking about it
it distracts you from the rest of your
life that's what an obsession does
when it's not really your obsession the
rest of your life distracts you from it
and so the it in your life is so
important but there's all these things
that distract us today i'm gonna give
you a recommendation turn your damn tv
off
turn the radio off most of the time turn
your phone off a lot too
so here's the deal the tv is competing
constantly to distract you with stuff
that really doesn't matter i'm not
saying by the way
don't be informed don't know what's
going on in the world because that makes
you more interesting right
you should know what's going on in the
world but let's be real does it really
matter what's going on with the
kardashians right now
does it really matter they live on my
street in one of my neighborhoods right
and
they're very nice people but i've got to
be honest with you what happens in their
life doesn't dramatically impact my but
how many people are more obsessed with
the kardashians
and i can say this is good friends we
have many good friends in reality
television they're even listening this
right now and they would tell you this
don't be so obsessed with them be
obsessed with your own reality tv
program called your own life
right how about the news all the time to
try to distract us before it was obama
now it's trump you better trump's going
crazy today obama was nuts about this
healthcare
iraq iran north korea right like all
these things
and most of these things don't impact
their own lives i'm not saying don't
know about them
but it's such a convenient escape from
the work it's such a convenient escape
from our obsessions
the left against the right republicans
against democrats who's going to be the
next president who's going to get the
democratic nomination can they beat
trump right who cares who cares right
now you got gotta win in your own life
i love the book by my brother evan
carmichael built to serve you guys this
is the kind of thing you get in this
book
most people wake up and drive to a job
they hate think about your five closest
friends
are they happy do they live their lives
with purpose do you
we put on a fake front for what we want
people to see and think about us
but the reality is most people aren't
happy we're lost we settle
you can't be happy if you don't know
your purpose and then he goes on to
explain how to do that
you guys should get this book built to
serve by my dear friend evan carmichael
rule number four get in control of your
mind with dandapani
when i was growing up as a child i was
teased
very often for being so distracted
teased for being distracted t so not
being able to concentrate
and you know had i not been born a few
decades ago i probably would have been
given one of those colorful
acronyms like add or adhd branded and
probably
drugged for not being able to
concentrate
right it wasn't till i was in my early
20s when
i graduated from university i grew up in
australia and i left
and went to hawaii where i joined my
guru's monastery was a cloistered
traditional hindu monastery
where he taught me how to concentrate
and that's really what i want you to
keep in mind this concept of being
taught how to concentrate
it's in my humble opinion that most
people can't concentrate today
for two reasons one is we're never
taught how to concentrate
and second is we don't practice
concentration
right so how can you do something if
you're never taught how to do it
and how can you be good at something if
you don't practice it
so if i wanted to play for the chicago
bulls or
dance for the san francisco ballet
company you know i ask people this
question all the time in my talks ask
them how many hours a day should i
practice
the general answer is usually about
eight hours a day six days a week
and then i asked them so after six
months can i play for the bulls
the answer is usually no after a year
no but i'd be better at basketball right
i'd be a better
ballet dancer so imagine if you practice
distraction
eight hours a day six days a week
what would you be good at after six
months
distraction after a year you'd be really
good at distraction
after a year and a half you'd be an
expert at distraction you'd like you'd
write the new york times
bestseller and distraction tedx would
invite you to come and give a keynote on
distraction
you'd get on stage you'd be so
distracted you forget what you were
supposed to talk about
right that's how good you are all right
but the truth is we don't practice
distraction
eight hours a day six days a week the
truth is we probably practice it more
like
16 hours a day seven days a week the
average person sleeps what seven to
eight hours
to say roughly so awake for about 16
hours of the day
let's just say on average we're
practicing it 13 hours a day
seven days a week distraction and then
you wonder why you're so good at it
that's the law of practice the law of
practice is that we become good
at whatever it is we practice whether
it's positive or negative it doesn't
matter if you practice something over
and over and over again
you become really good at it and that's
why people are so good at distraction
because it's what they practice why
aren't people good at concentration
because they never taught it and they
never practice it
they don't need to be drugged they just
need to be taught how to do it
children don't need to be drugged they
just need to be taught
how to concentrate and then they need to
practice it just like anything else to
become a good tennis player
to become a good dancer the performer
anything
practice practice practice so how do we
become
good at concentrating we start by
understanding the mind
right all of us have a mind it's the
most powerful tool in the world
built a smartphone it's put
machines that drive itself on mars yet
there's no manual for the mind
right when was the last time you saw a
manual for the mind
yet you you buy a point-and-shoot camera
whose only purpose
and duty is to point and shoot it comes
with a 100-page manual
right yet we have the most complex tool
in the world on mine
and there's no manual so the first thing
i learned when i went to the monastery
was to learn
how the mind works because once you know
how the mind works
you can control it and once you can
control it you can focus it
you can't focus or concentrate something
you don't understand
so how does the mind work from the
monk's perspective from the monk's
experience of the mind
there's two things that you need to
understand
one is there's awareness and one is the
mind
so i'll take a few moments to explain
this to you and share what they are so
imagine awareness is a glowing ball of
light
like an orb that can float around okay
so that's awareness
now imagine your mind as a vast space
vast
area with many different sections within
it one area of the mind is anger
jealousy food sex happiness
joy signs are and this glowing ball of
light call awareness can travel within
the mind
and it can go to any area of the mind it
wants to go to
and when it goes to a particular area of
the mind it lights up that area
when it lights up that area of the mind
you become conscious of it
so give you an example your friend
invites you to go see a movie for
example okay
hey doug do you want to go see mission
impossible 16
sure let's go okay so you go to the
theater you're watching
you know you sit down the light's all on
you're chatting with your friend the
lights dim
the movie starts if it's a really great
director or producer he or she
can take your awareness to any area of
the mind they want you to go to right
they can take you to a sad area of mind
to happy area of the mind the movie can
get really exciting
thrilling suspenseful scary
and it's 90 minutes later you see two
words on the screen and it says
the end and you turn to your friend and
you go like wow that was an amazing
movie
but you paid 13 or 14 or 15
or whatever it is to allow the director
to take your awareness to different
areas of the mind
and this happens on a daily basis each
day we allow someone or something
throughout the day
to take our awareness from one ear of
the mind to another
when we allow a person or something to
do that we're being distracted
the art of concentration is the art of
keeping awareness that ball of light
on one thing for an extended period of
time
every time that ball of light drifts
away we bring it back
it drifts away again we bring it back
and rule number five the last one before
a very special bonus clip
is shut out the distractions with robert
greene
there's differences and then there's
there's not differences
so um you know the brain is the same
the brain evolved over the course of
millions of years
so i try to make the point that
you know what da vinci was going through
the process is
there's a template there and it's the
same because
our brains haven't really changed in an
evolutionary sense
in four or five hundred years on the
other hand the circumstances are
different and people now live
in a world where there's many more
distractions so it's harder to do that
kind of focus that i
was mentioning so in some ways it's a
little bit harder
and the people that i've interviewed are
really good
at shutting out all of the distractions
of the world that's sort of what
separates them
every single one of them uh paul graham
you know paul graham
paul doesn't have a smartphone yeah
uh he doesn't spend time on the internet
he's extremely focused the woman
yokimatsuoka
she she does all of her writing with a
pen and paper she's not
sitting there day in and day out on the
computer
checking her facebook or twitter page or
whatever i could go through all of them
that way steve jobs is sort of the
ultimate icon
of mastery of our era and he said the
only thing that's
differentiated me from everyone else was
my level of focus
i could take a problem and i could focus
on it and burrow into it
and everybody else was so distracted he
knew how to close his door
get away from his wife his kids everyone
and just focus
so the all of these people have to
overcome the intense distractions in our
world
and they're able to do it on the other
hand what you can get with a click
on the internet with a google search
compared to what da vinci had to do or a
scientist in the 19th or 20th century is
absolutely
astounding so what you have at your
fingertips the knowledge
the things that you can connect and
learn about the potential for learning
skills is
out of this world so if you're able to
overcome the distracting
elements that are it's i i my girlfriend
i compare it
to if you ever watch a basketball game
and
you see the opposing team shooting free
throw and everyone behind
him and the stands are all going like
this with those big
you know trying to distract him there's
like hundreds of people that's what the
world is like now
you've got thousands of people waving
those things you've got so many
distractions if you're able to overcome
that
and be a person that can focus you have
this like
wealth of information and knowledge and
ability to acquire skills
that nobody 100 years ago 20 years ago
could dream about
now i've got a special bonus clip on how
to focus on your distractions that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question today i
want to know
which of these five ways do you need to
apply most right now to your life or
business
let me know put it down in the comments
below and if you made it this far in a
video you're still here watching and you
promise you commit to yourself that
you're gonna take
action we don't just watch videos here
believe nation we do something about it
give me a hashtag believe down the
comments below if that's you
so i can celebrate with you too the
thing that you keep getting distracted
by
might be the very thing that you should
be focusing on so many people keep
asking me hey evan how do i stop getting
distracted how do i focus on my work
if you keep getting distracted it's for
one of two reasons
either one you don't like the work that
you're doing or two you're afraid of it
working out
the solution isn't to keep avoiding it
the solution is through
and chances are that thing you keep
getting distracted by
is actually the thing that you should be
focusing on you just don't know how to
make it a business
yet now i'm a big believer and as soon
as you get an idea you test you try you
tinker you experiment idea to action the
two percent difference let's go let's go
let's go
so a quick example with my top 10 series
when i first started the top 10 series
i didn't think it would become a series
i didn't think it would become
this huge thing that then later defined
my channel and became
the most popular series on my youtube
channel it started off because a friend
of mine mark posted a blog
about kanye west and how he interrupted
taylor swift
and this was multiple years after he had
actually done that and like
come on man you can learn from kanye
dude
stop hating on kanye yes he gets himself
into trouble
he deserves it but he's also a genius
he's also someone that you could learn
from
he's won more grammy awards than anybody
at his age he convinced john stevens to
change his name to john legend
because it had an old school voice it's
all these amazing stories about kanye
that you can learn from his success
and so i thought forget this i'm not
just going to complain
i'm going to take action and i'm going
to make a top 10 rules for success
from kanye west and i went out myself
and researched all these different clips
and i put them together and sure there's
a lot that you can't learn from kanye
there's a lot that you don't want to
model or copy
and emulate into your life and business
i get it but there's still 10 things at
least
you can apply and learn from him to make
you a better version of you
and so i just did it and i released it
and people liked it it was meant to be a
one-off video
just to show my friend mark to say just
watch this mark
watch it learn from it you could learn
from kanye
and it was a distraction project right
i'm working on my business
i'm working on trying to create
something mark creates this blog post
and i get distracted by it and think i
want to make a video and i put my
business
on hold instead of saying no no forget
that idea i need to stop doing
that i need to i need you to just focus
and forget all distractions
no i said you know i'm going to put this
on hold because i can't stop thinking
about this
so i'm going to do this get it out of my
system and then i'm going to come back
to my main business
although that little thing that i did
just as a one-off to show my friend mark
ended up becoming
the entire channel you never know
and so it's idea to action that thing
that i got distracted by
ended up becoming the beginning of an
entire series
an iconic series on my channel and it
might be the thing for you too
[Music]
if you want to know the best routines
and habits for success check out my
video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there there is one habit
that i have adopted in the last three
years
that has fundamentally changed me as a
business person